alors pour commencer je veux que tu
saches que je comprends vous comprenez
quoi le lycée comme balla camara à
nouveau t-shirt avengers c'est chou
elles font que je suis fille bizarre est
bizarre les garçons excuse moi
tu marques sur ma chemise
alors tu t'es battu par la fenêtre
d'autant qu'ils monde imaginaire
[Applaudissements]
kamala et tu es là je t'en prie
concentre toi je vais devoir découvrir
tout mon avenir avant le déjeuner ou vos
parce que
[Musique]
ils ont peut-être pas tort
je passe mon temps
vivre dans un monde imaginaire
ce n'est pas toi cette tenue
c'est pas vraiment les filles comme moi
vivent ailleurs society qui sauve le
monde
c'était dans mon imagination ça aussi
il était arrivé quelque chose non
pourquoi tu as entendu parler de marca
malin
quel effet ça fait
cosmique
j'ai toujours cru que je voulais ce
genre de vie
mais j'avais jamais imaginé tout ça
est ce que tu sais au moins ce que tu es
je suis super héroïne
[Musique]